nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15
off go to nebia.com pacman and use the
code pacman
one of the things i've been talking
about for a few weeks now is
what i see is the underselling of the
coronavirus vaccines
as something that could well be making
people less interested in getting
vaccinated when you see endless
headlines about
even if you're vaccinated you can't do
anything differently you can't hang out
with people you can't do indoors
you have to wear a mask you can't travel
you can't visit anybody all of this
different stuff
and we've been expecting new guidelines
from the cdc
in conjunction with the dramatically
accelerating vaccination
numbers that we talked about yesterday
and we got it
the big news to skip to sort of the meat
of the announcement
is that the cdc now says vaccinated
people
can safely gather indoors without masks
with
other vaccinated people without social
distancing you can hug
vaccinated people can also be with
unvaccinated people
if the unvaccinated people are of low
risk and there's a few other things
let's look at
cdc director uh walensky telling us this
yesterday
cdc recommends that fully vaccinated
people can visit with other
fully vaccinated people in small
gatherings indoors
without wearing masks or physical
distancing remember here we are talking
about
private settings where everyone is
vaccinated
so what does this mean if you and a
friend or you and a family member are
both vaccinated
you can have dinner together wearing
masks without distancing
you can visit your grandparents if you
have been vaccinated and
they have been too now
i want to talk to you about another more
complicated scenario
it involves vaccinated people visiting
with unvaccinated people
when fully vaccinated people visit with
unvaccinated people
we have to consider the underlying risks
of the unvaccinated people
and any unvaccinated members of their
household
we take this approach because all of our
guidance is rooted in making
sure we are keeping people safe
so cdc recommends that fully vaccinated
people
can visit with unvaccinated people from
one
other household indoors without wearing
masks or physical distancing
as long as the unvaccinated people and
any unvaccinated members of their
household
are not at high risk for severe covet 19
disease so additionally
vaccinated people can gather indoors
unmasked
with unvaccinated people from the same
household
assuming that the unvaccinated people
are low risk
so the point here is the vaccines are
extremely effective all essentially 100
effective at preventing serious covet
and death
uh and they appear to reduce
transmission more on that
in a moment and on this basis
it is time for certain elements
to start going in the direction of
re-normalization now
vaccinated people should not go hang out
with a
year high-risk unvaccinated person
fortunately
increasingly a majority of those over 60
have now been vaccinated at least with
one shot in the united states majority
not all
to put it a different way vaccinated
grandparents
can visit unvaccinated healthy kids and
grandkids
but vaccinated kids should not be
visiting unvaccinated
grandparents um i i will be paying very
close attention to this household thing
being vaccinated myself my girlfriend
being vaccinated i have friends who are
couples and work from home who aren't
yet vaccinated
that seems safe and that's in accordance
with what the cdc says
two couples from different households
especially
if one doesn't work from home i'm not
going to get into that kind of
situation for the foreseeable future so
this is a big step forward
the science seems increasingly clear on
how effective these vaccines are
at preventing death serious illness
increasingly clear that they also
reduce transmissibility although that's
still being studied the cdc said
yesterday
a quote growing body of evidence
suggests people who are vaccinated
are not only less likely to have
asymptomatic infections but also
potentially less likely to transmit the
virus still
they aren't ruling out the possibility
that a vaccinated person could
inadvertently transmit the virus we're
going to learn more about that over the
coming weeks and months
also from the cdc yesterday vaccinated
people don't need to quarantine or get
tested if they have a known exposure to
the virus
assuming they don't develop symptoms so
this would be
you find out someone you work with if
you're working in an office
someone you work with has tested
positive you are vaccinated
you do not need to go through an
isolation and quarantine protocol if you
are vaccinated
unless you develop a symptom vaccinated
people
should be avoiding large and medium
gatherings still everybody should
and of course none of these guidelines
change
anything for vaccinated people out in
public if a grocery store says masks
then everyone wears masks regardless of
vaccination stat
status that should be obvious that makes
absolute perfect sense
so hopefully and we're going to have a
very interesting interview later today
with jonathan berman about
the vaccine hesitancy which is
fortunately waning in the united states
on the covet vaccine
hopefully this increases the number of
people who get vaccinated since
the more that that do get vaccinated
number one the more people that can get
into this new protocol
outlined by the cdc but also the faster
we can go to the next step of relaxation
of guidelines now some states are just
relaxing all guidelines now
texas mississippi some other scheduling
further relaxation is going to
wide open everything no masks anywhere
i believe that there will be people who
will want the vaccine
because now it's in black and white from
the cdc you get vaccinated and your
parents do
you can hang out and you can hug and
these are things that
many people in parts of the country
haven't done
for um really almost a year we're about
a week from
the one year mark from the trump
announcement that travel from certain
countries is being banned and sort of
the beginning
of quarantines for those who have been
doing them
that's what's going on in terms of what
vaccinated people can do
let's now go to our weekly covet update
as to the numbers which continue to
improve fortunately
the united states had its least bad
day in terms of covid yesterday that it
has had
in nearly six months dating all the way
back to september of 2020.
now we were worried after seeing a
precipitous decline
starting in mid-january in cases and
deaths and hospitalizations
that it was leveling out and even
averages crept up
for a period of about four or five days
a couple of weeks ago
that has now further reversed and we are
on the way back down
and that is such welcome good news
where for a year there has been very
little good news this is our weekly
covet update
deaths continue down cases continue down
hospitalizations continue down
as vaccinations continue climbing now
averaging more
than 2.1 million vaccinations a day over
the last week let's go through them one
by one
first of all cases remember cases peaked
on
a january 11th at an average of 255
000 cases per day an insane number
we are now down 77 percent
to about 58 000 cases a day
over the last week still a long way to
go remember dr
fauci says we can't really think about
normality
until we of course have way more people
vaccinated but until cases get below 10
000 cases a day
but being down 77 is a great thing
secondly deaths deaths peaked
uh with an average of about 3 400 deaths
a day more than a 911 a day
in the last few days of january deaths
are down
to a still tragic 1600 per day
that is a decline of 53 percent it's an
indicator that things are going in the
right direction
it's hard to feel good about 600 people
a day dying
and i don't feel good about it but at
least we are down to that number rather
than seeing deaths
climb remember that deaths lag cases by
several weeks so we would hope that in a
few weeks
we would be down 77 in deaths the way we
are down
77 percent in cases today next
indicator and this is increasingly an
important indicator
uh debt deaths lag cases by a period of
time
cases also depend on testing
hospitalizations
is a really important indicator to be
looking at as people get vaccinated
hospitalizations
new hospitalizations daily are down
from their peak of about 18 000 people
going into the hospital each day with
covet in mid-january
18 000 was the peak down to about 5 000
a day
lately again hard to feel good about
every day
5 000 people have to go into the
hospital because of covid
but it's a decline of 72 percent that is
huge
and then total cumulative people in the
hospital
at one point we had 125 000 people in
the u.s
hospitalized with covid that is down to
30
000 that's a decline in hospitalizations
of 76
so these are dramatically improving
numbers
that must continue to decline now what
about the variance
i have good news about variance the fear
is
the vaccines won't work against variants
that's been the fear
we have a new england journal of
medicine report
of the three major variants the three
major bearings are what's called the
b117 variant
that's the uk variant the b 1351 variant
that's the south african
variant and then the p1 variant which is
the brazilian
variant a study looked at
neutralization of those variants with
serum from people who have been
vaccinated fully
two pfizer doses and then you wait the
one to two weeks
the data is very good i'm putting up a
complicated image for our video audience
if it looks confusing don't worry what
we are looking at here
are um these three variants i mentioned
plus two subsets of the south african
variant
all of the serum samples so the idea is
you get serum from vaccinated people
the serum has antibodies those
uh serum samples efficiently
neutralized all of the virus variants
that is really good news but let's let's
be cautious
the cautious piece is basically two
things number one
primarily with the south african variant
and secondarily with the brazilian
variant
the level of neutralization is closer to
the minimum
necessary to defeat the virus so what
that means is the vaccines
appear to be enough in most cases
to defeat these variants but it's closer
to borderline which means that in some
people if you don't generate as many
antibodies
because the antibody generation is on a
on a distribution curve and some people
will be at the lower end of the curve
which can be by chance or due to a
condition
that affects your immune system it will
be more borderline whether the vaccine
will completely protect you from the
south african or brazilian variants
it would be closer to escaping the
vaccine
but in most people you you will not uh
you will be protected
and even if you're not and most people
who don't get enough protection against
those variants
you would get a very mild uh mild
illness a cold sniffles etc
last sort of caveat these are serum
tests
in labs in the real world with
people you would expect that it would
not be as
open and shut as the data is in these
serum tests but it is still as
reassuring as we would hope
based on the significant doom and gloom
about
the variance escape the vaccine period
does not appear to be true based on
everything we know right now so let's
keep it going
this is not the time to ease up let's
continue to to push for the declines
and we're we're within months of a
significant return
to normalization if we can keep going on
vaccination
and doing what what most states have
been doing
remember march 26th one day
membership blowout we had an
unfortunately
really bad month from the standpoint of
memberships in february
a lot of people still hit with the
economic destruction of the virus having
to cancel their memberships
february being a shorter month uh not as
many people signing up so we are doing a
one-day membership special
the theme of it will be vaccine related
and it'll be march 26th if you want to
be notified about that special just get
on my mailing list at davidpakman.com
and you will get a a perfect email on
the morning of march 26
telling you how to avail yourself of
this discount and of course let me know
how things are going in your state as
far as vaccinations go by finding me on
twitter at dpac the david pakman show at
davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market
it has twice the coverage of other
shower heads the water sprays with a ton
of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it only took a few minutes
to set up
really easy and it's been a totally
different experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about half
as much
water nebia also offers a number of
shower accessories like shelves and
curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
pacman and use code pacman will get 15
percent off
all nebia products
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
we are an audience supported program and
i would love it if you grabbed a
membership at joinpackman.com you will
get the daily bonus show on which today
i will weigh in
people urgently wanting me to weigh in
on megan markell
just kidding meghan markle uh and uh the
prince and the interview with oprah and
we're going to have a conversation i'm
actually more interested in the sort of
media apparatus
around which these interviews are done
less so than the content of the
interview but we'll talk about that and
more things on today's bonus show
and you can get access to the bonus show
by
signing up at joinpakman.com yesterday
the supreme court denied donald trump's
absolute
final last remaining attempt to cancel
out his election loss
in wisconsin the supreme court order was
unsigned with no noted dissent simply
saying
justices are declining to take to
declining to take up donald trump's
lawsuit
this is the lawsuit in which donald
trump claims wisconsin's election
officials violated
the constitution by letting more people
vote absentee
due to the pandemic remember that joe
biden won wisconsin by about 20
000 votes donald trump sued over those
results about a month
after the 2020 election this is now if
you are keeping track
more than 60 total losses and one
narrow win which did nothing for trump
in terms of the election
when trump went to court over the
election now just because they rejected
the case doesn't mean that nobody at the
supreme court
wanted to hear the case the court's
denial of trump's appeal yesterday
means that fewer than four justices
agreed to hear the case
it's conceivable that one two or three
of them did actually want to take this
case and
recently a few of the more right-wing
justices suggested
they might actually be interested in
looking at issues relating to
what the constitution says about the
authority
that states have to decide how to run an
election including things like
expanding absentee ballots during a
pandemic to everyone who
wants one here we don't know if zero
one two or three justices wanted to hear
the case
only that not enough wanted to hear it
uh
and thus they will not be hearing the
case now i should also mention
and this is this is really a bigger
story about the psyche of the american
right
at this point in time even if the
supreme court decided to take this case
it's all pointless it's a and it's
pointless for a few reasons
number one it's not clear that you can
nullify an election
after the electoral votes have been
certified
and counted and the next president is in
office
even if somehow the supreme court had
taken this case
and the supreme court decided wisconsin
should not have expanded absentee voting
and somehow
that led to so give wisconsin to trump
which also is no foregone conclusion
even if the case were taken up by the
court and they decided
the absentee ballot shouldn't have been
expanded that doesn't even mean trump
gets the state
but even if trump did get the state it
still doesn't
give donald trump enough electoral votes
to get to 270
and so it's all pointless but this is
this is officially the last remaining
loose end
and as i was reading about this this
morning my takeaway is
you know as we learned as we approached
march 4th
when there were many people who thought
trump is going to get re-inaugurated on
march 4th the day came and went and of
course it didn't happen
there are a significant number of people
in this country
who believe as an ongoing matter that
it's plausible
that once the term of a new president
has started
that courts might just say they're out
previous guy goes in and the previous
president would just be reinstated
because of some kind of
overlooked mistake somewhere in there
where oh people in wisconsin
shouldn't have been allowed to vote
absentee for any reason like the idea
being
the president is it's just some guy
and they could be replaced at any time
and it would just be kind of like no big
deal trump they
someone would just say john roberts
would bang a gavel i don't know if the
supreme court has gavels at this point
uh would bang a figurative gavel a
proverbial gavel and and
biden's escorted out and trump is
escorted back in like the idea that
that's even a possibility
shows you how either ignorant or deeply
committed to these delusions so many
people
are and part of the reason why is that
right-wing media for the last four
months
has essentially been based on the idea
even if they don't say it when fox news
newsmax oan
rush limbaugh while he was still doing
his show and alive etc
they they run on the idea all the time
that the reason for their principled
conservatism
is that tradition is super sacred things
can't be modified
history precedent tradition norms but in
this case it's like if amy coney barrett
decides they're going to do it they pull
by now
two months into his term and say
somebody else is going to replace him
and it really shouldn't be that
surprising because these are the same
people
even the ones that didn't participate in
the january 6th riots
many believed that storming the capital
with whatever violence they deemed to be
necessary
could theoretically prevent joe biden
from becoming president it's the same
ideology if if you think that maybe
march 4th biden gets yanked out
or maybe the supreme court in march or
april or may
decides biden out trump in if you
believe that's possible
you're probably the same type of person
who believes we might be able to
physically do
something in washington dc on the sixth
that will give donald trump
a second term and many of them their
ignorance was weaponized by the fact
that they were able to be convinced of
that
and that's that this is really the
bigger principle of
modern american conservatism it's the
old idea of conservatism we must
maintain traditional values
and ideas and procedures and resist
change
for the in-groups right
but if all of a sudden those values and
protocols and traditions
protect or bolster some out group
be it democrats or minorities or whoever
else
then the principles go in the trash and
something like a violent
uprising on january 6th to prevent biden
from being president despite winning
seems like a reasonable and acceptable
thing to do that's modern conservatism
and it is
based in the hypocrisy we've seen from
the republican party for a long time
i often talk about the importance
of learning and teaching media literacy
media criticism
epistemology the thinking arts so to
speak
and i also talk about the absolute and
total lack of those
in our country among large swaths of the
population
today i'm going to go through one
90-second news max clip newsmax is this
kind of radical alternative to fox news
and we're going to try to look at how
many lies how many distortions how many
baseless assumptions can we find
so this is it's actually kind of hard
for me to tell you what this segment is
about
i guess the segment is sort of about
so-called cancel culture type content
and um the segment claims that the left
is nothing short of
marxist authoritarian dictators of some
kind
so let's take it piece by piece and
you're going to see how quickly
there builds a pyramid of so much that
is
wrong in this segment and because
there's so much unless you are really
armed with critical thinking faculties
just by the sheer number of deceptions
and misstatements here
you'll probably fall for some of it so
let's begin with the first part of this
here today our culture this is happening
marxists have used the hollow shell of
the democratic party
to ascend to power okay so there are no
marxists
in the american democratic party the
closest
you might get in the senate is bernie
who calls himself a democratic socialist
maybe he was a democratic socialist in
his younger years
he advocates for standard northern
european social democracy
not marxism there's no marxism in the
u.s senate in
the house okay aoc calls herself a
democratic socialist
there are some other members of congress
who use that term they aren't marxists
and certainly no marxists have any power
in the united states they've not taken
over the democratic party
in any way shape or form so already the
segment is lined up
with a bogus framing a bogus base to
this pyramid of disinformation
let's keep going and do what they have
always wanted to do
in this country and what they do in
every country destroy the history
and culture of the nation that they have
taken over no history has been destroyed
and certainly no culture has been
destroyed culture evolved
culture is something that evolves over
time a politically
economically intellectual culture all
participants in a culture
shape it either explicitly or implicitly
it's essentially a meaningless
fear-mongering statement meant to
resonate in what we know are the
fear-oriented brains
of conservatives next clip this year
alone we have seen kermit the frog
mr potato head dr seuss star wars
characters
pancake syrup butter and beloved sports
teams logos
banned erased from history now this one
is really a doozy
none of that is true in any real sense
and
this is a gish gallop the whole segment
is a gish gala but this set of examples
is a it's a it's a gish gallop within a
gish gallop
kermit the frog some episodes have
depictions
of native americans and middle eastern
people that are not great
and some muppet show episodes now have a
warning at the beginning they're not
banned they have a warning
at the beginning mr potato head had its
franchise name
changed to potato head both mr
and mrs potato head still exist dr
seuss we've been talking about the
publishing company decided not to keep
publishing
six books due to stereotypes of asian
people in them
nothing is banned star wars characters i
guess he's referring to the mandalorian
star
gina carano who was fired because she
implied that being a republican today is
like being jewish during the holocaust
and a private company decided what's
good for them it's not very marxist for
private for-profit companies
to be allowed to do whatever they want
but that is market capitalism that we
have in the united states
pancake syrup is aunt jemima syrup being
renamed because the imagery of aunt
jemima is quite
crass today uh given how it stereotypes
black americans
the syrup is still around it's just
called pearl milling it's it's
not on jemima anymore butter i don't
even know what he's talking about i
wasn't even able to find anything on
that one
sports team logos yes you know uh
washington redskins with a caricature
of a red-skinned native american
stereotype
um it just doesn't it's unflattering and
it's inappropriate at this point and the
team decided this is bad for us so we're
going to change the team name
and now the host says these aren't
merely decisions by private companies
these are not simply marketing choices
of private companies
we want to emphasize this joe biden's
white house endorses
these modern day book burnings the white
house the most powerful seat in our land
biden broke with long-standing tradition
and refused to acknowledge
dr seuss on his birthday this very week
he refused to recommend that children
read beloved dr seuss books
so he implies joe biden has weighed in
on that list of things he gave
and joe biden hasn't joe biden went
along with what read across america day
did
which is they don't include dr seuss
biden hasn't endorsed any of the other
stuff the guy listed he hasn't even
mentioned most of it at all
one more clip here amazon then stopped
selling certain dr seuss titles and
publishers halted printing them
entirely here are real screenshots from
an ebay user
getting blocked for trying to sell a dr
seuss book
because it is and i quote offensive
material
we verified these images are real what's
also real
real shocking is that hitler's mind conf
is still available for sale on ebay
this is a book literally about racism
this is a book
literally calling for book burnings you
cannot make this
up so then he raises amazon should
amazon not be allowed to do what they
want i mean
is it is the argument from free market
capitalist newsmax
that amazon shouldn't be allowed amazon
should be
forced to do something ebay should be
forced
to sell books who would force them the
government that's not small government
concern
conservatism and arguably his only maybe
good point comes at the end
which is why is hitler's book still
available shouldn't there be some
consistency here
i personally think there should be that
being said
it's ultimately the decision of ebay so
there is essentially
nothing in this rant that is accurate or
relevant to the real world
but people watch this stuff and they
fall hook line and sinker for it
let me know what you think we'll have
more coverage of these
types of segments on the david pakman
show instagram page find us there at
david pakman show
find me on instagram david.pacman as
well
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's
join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
welcome back to the david pakman show
today i'm going to be speaking with
jonathan berman who's a professor
national co-chair of the 2017 march for
science and
also author of anti-vaxxers how to
challenge
a misinformed movement jonathan so great
to have you on today
thank you thank you for having me here
so let's see to start with
my conception of the anti-vaccine
movement which
which i've studied over time is that you
have
um right and left-wing so-called
anti-vaccine folks often motivated in
different ways i tend to see
the the right-wing anti-vaccine is more
based in skepticism of
government whereas the left-wing
anti-vaccine is more skepticism of big
pharma so first question
am i right that this sometimes crosses
political lines is it along the lines i
i laid out
yeah for the most part uh so
up until very recently there wasn't a
big difference between
left and right as far as vaccine
skepticism over the last few years
there's been a pretty big right word
shift um
i just was reading a paper indicating
that there's a strong
um the second strongest predictor of
anti-vaccine sentiment right now is
christian nationalism
so there there have been some some
change changes in the demographic
makeup of the anti-vaccine movement like
you would expect with a big event like
the pandemic going on
what would you say so currently maybe
we'll start
now and maybe work backwards if it makes
sense we've seen
vaccine skepticism over the coronavirus
vaccine
decline overall over the last year i
think there was a point last year where
something like 60
of americans said they weren't
interested and that dropped to 50 and
the latest numbers i saw about 28
28 or 30 percent is the is the current
situation unique historically or is it
typical that when there is the the
surges of a new communicable disease
that there is more hesitancy that
declines
you know i was initially skeptical of
those
those survey numbers for the reason that
for diseases like measles uh we
we've seen you know high degrees of
skepticism on surveys
but then when it comes when the when the
rubber hits the road when it's time to
actually get vaccinated
we see very high numbers of vaccination
high compliance
so there's there's something about the
way those surveys tend to be written
or or something about the way
that uh that that people respond
to them that that makes
people a little bit uh
hesitant to say they're going to get it
but then
get it so when it was saying 40
30 i think it's going to be higher than
that um
so it's not surprising that as people
get vaccinated people are
are relaxing a little bit about their
skepticism
one of the things i would imagine will
will move
some people who might genuinely be on
the skeptical side
to the i want the vaccine side would be
if airlines for example say after a
certain date you'll need to be
vaccinated to fly with us
or you can avoid a quarantine if you're
vaccinated or if you want to come to an
event where tickets are sold by
ticketmaster or live nation you'll need
to be vaccinated i think that that that
will certainly be
a factor um but beyond those sort of
i want to be able to do x type of things
what
tends to bring people out of vaccine
skepticism
right so as far as what governments can
do
like you said you have these
non-coercive measures
um and ideally we don't want to be
coercing people
because that's when people become most
resistant
is when they feel like they're being
coerced so
what what seems to help is seeing people
who
belong to the same groups as them
getting vaccinated people who have
similar backgrounds similar
socioeconomic status
similar race and religion um
getting vaccinated and the united states
um
so for example there is strong vaccine
hesitancy in the black community
right um but that's partially predicated
on a history of
of medical racism and addressing that
is going to be an important part of
persuading people in that community
may be less important for persuading
orthodox jews or or white
evangelicals um so
i think the most important thing we can
do is to sort of target our messaging
to the groups we're speaking to um
that's interesting yeah the the three
currently most vaccine hesitant groups
that i looked at and again this is as
you mentioned if we can if we can trust
the data
uh it's black americans um republicans
and those without college degrees what
would
it be that would be more likely to be um
convincing
to for example just republicans
right so there's this moral foundations
theory
in in psychology that says that uh
people who tend to
be more conservative respond more to
certain
moral foundations that people tend to be
more respond to other moral
foundations right so the ones that
conservatives
um i think respond more to are
um sort of disgust loyalty
um and so we want to frame messaging
around
those moral foundations in my opinion so
we would want to
[Music]
you know talk about when people say
these are chemicals these are
outside substances you're putting in
your body what's really in there what
does it mean
what's it there for um and
then have the discussion with them about
bodily autonomy control over
what medical treatments are being
performed on them and and make sure it's
clear that this is not
a case of government overreach and that
public health measures are an important
part of the functions of of government
that
um they should hopefully accept yeah
jonathan jonathan height has written
a lot about what you know the the as you
point out the values that
um are more relevant and motivational to
different
different groups of people when it comes
to vaccine
skepticism are there examples from
history where it was justified to be
skeptical of a vaccine
um so there have been instances in
history where
things have gone wrong and there were
mistakes made in manufacturing of a
vaccine
or we're welcoming we're welcoming your
dog to the interview now which is fine
the audience loves dogs
um sadie sees a sees someone outside
delivering a package and she's very
angry
say hi to sadie there she is nice edie
um
so yeah there have been instances in the
past where
mistakes have been made or in
manufacturing or
where in the 70s there was a
flu pandemic that was predicted that
never came about
and there was a vaccine that very
slightly
increased the risk of guillain-barre
syndrome right
so those things have happened in the
past
um and that's why it's not unreasonable
to be cautious
right so that's why we hit we test
vaccines with
thousands and thousands of people before
they come to market and that's why
these things are reviewed by government
panels and these are
you know the saying is regulations are
written in blood
um a lot of these regulations have come
about because of those mistakes
um a really big important one was
uh the qatar and wyeth labs incident in
the 1950s
there was about 200 000 doses of polio
vaccine
right um and
the that vaccine design involved live
polio virus that was inactivated it was
it wasn't killed because viruses aren't
alive but it was made unable to infect
people
with i believe it was formaldehyde
and it was improperly done so
this uh this vaccine that was sent out
was able to infect people
and so about 200 people had a
paralyzed limb where they were injected
or with
with that vaccine and so that led to the
creation of some of these government
agencies that are responsible for
that regulation you know one that i've
been
getting maybe you know 10 or 12 emails
about
over the last few weeks as we've talked
about vaccines is folks who write to me
and say
you know david clearly vaccines
can do harm because there is this
vaccine
injury compensation apparatus that the
government
uh has has created and that
that wouldn't be there if this wasn't a
thing so therefore
therefore what i guess is the question
right
so the the national vaccine injury
compensation program came about in the
1980s
and there had been a paper in 1974
that alleged or seemed that seemed to
show that there was
from the tdap vaccine
an increased risk of
neurological problems
and so that led to people saying oh is
that true
and a bunch of studies eventually we
figured out no it's not true
but the consequences of that were a wave
of countries
deciding that they would no longer
um no longer vaccinate for
i'm sorry dpt vaccine theory process
yeah uh they would no longer vaccinate
for pertussis
and there was a wave of outbreaks that
followed in those countries
where pertussis came back whooping cough
a lot of sick kids and in the u.s
there were only a handful of companies
that manufactured pertussis vaccine
so lawyers saw this and they decided
okay we're going to start suing
these companies manufacturing dpt and
we'll use this paper as evidence
and so there were there were was at
least one
i believe possibly two companies that
went out that said we're not going to
make it anymore it's too big a liability
we'll be sued out of existence and
congress saw this and they realized that
if we continue allowing people to sue
based on flimsy evidence
[Music]
these vaccine manufacturers we won't
have a vaccine supply
so they kind of came up with this idea
that's not perfect
and which is uh the the national vaccine
injury compensation program
so excuse me if you
are vaccinated then in the next few days
you develop certain symptoms you
are certain that they have defined as
possible
vaccine injury they will compensate you
and you can go to the vaccine court and
the government will compensate you
instead of suing the vaccine
manufacturer out of existence
um and that's not perfect because that
takes away some of the liability if they
actually do do something wrong
right and how common are the claims
um i don't have the number off the top
of my head it's fairly common for people
to file claims
um they have paid out a lot over time
the trouble is that the standard of
evidence required by the vaccine court
is very different from the scientific
standard of evidence that
i or other scientists would require to
to say this is
this is demonstrated to my satisfaction
as provisionally true in the lab
right so it's a standard that that
allows
maybe for more successful filings than
a a a a more rigorous method would
yeah um so legal proceedings don't
always
track with scientific methods right
yeah um listen last thing i wanted to
touch on when it comes to the rollout of
the coronavirus vaccine we now have the
pfizer and moderna vaccines
um approved and they've been out through
emergency use they've been out for a bit
i've received both doses of the moderna
we now have the approved
via eua johnson and johnson we may have
a fourth vaccine on the way
i'm reassured right now by two things
one we have gone from 890
000 vaccinations a day to 2.1 million
that number seems to continue to climb
number two the latest study i saw in the
new england journal of medicine on
effectiveness against the three primary
variants uk
brazil and south africa uh is remains
quite good
so in total is it logical to be pretty
optimistic right now about the next four
to six months
i am both optimistic and worried i'm
optimistic because
uh for the reasons you state we've done
a we've started to do a good job
of ramping up the rate of vaccination
and
the vaccines are pretty good for those
variants however
here's why i'm i'm worried
there are the brazilian and the new york
city variants
the brazilian variant seems to escape
immunity
from people who've already been infected
with
uh with coronavirus so in other words
vaccines aside
vaccines if you got the virus a year ago
and then you get the brazilian variant
today
you you are not immune from the old
infection you you may not
you may not be okay um so that's
something to watch and
and be concerned about we don't know yet
that vaccines don't provide better
protection
right um but it's something to be
concerned about and
the new york city variant um
is still a question mark it that seems
to be infecting people
faster than you would expect given the
number of cases new york city has
already had
in other words still not based on
vaccination but based on
new york city having a lot of early
infections
and yet they're having a lot of new
infections with that variant
yes and the other reason i'm worried is
that there is some
inequity in the distribution of the
vaccine yes so 10 countries
have i think 70 of the available vaccine
um and there are more than 10 countries
in the world yes
so so it's going to take i think up
until 2024 2025 until
vaccine can be distributed worldwide
um and because viruses don't care about
national borders
um that means coronavirus is going to be
something
that we deal with for a very long time
even if
countries wealthy countries do a great
job of vaccinating
and and regardless in all circumstances
the quicker we can vaccinate now the
better
everybody is right i mean all else being
equal
that's right so right now the way i see
it we're in a race yeah
um and the race is between the mutation
rate
of these coronavirus variants
and vaccination so the faster we can
vaccinate people
the fewer cases there are the fewer
chances to mutate there are
makes up makes makes perfect sense
jonathan berman professor
national co-chair of the 2017 march for
science and also
author of anti-vaxxers how to challenge
a misinformed movement
i really appreciate your time today
thank you so much sorry about my doggy
no everybody loves the dog the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media
and you can contribute any amount you
want on patreon as little as one dollar
per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
there is an absolutely fascinating and
chaotic war
that has developed between donald trump
and the republican party
it has the makings of exactly the type
of chaos that could endanger
both donald trump's political future and
also the viability of the republican
party in the 2022 election cycle and not
surprisingly
this is all about money back at his cpac
speech a couple of weeks back
donald trump announced that he was not
yet announcing whether he would run in
2024 he said we'll see how it goes
but that for now donate to him at
donaldj
trump.com so that through his save
america pack
he can support the right republican
candidates in 2022
and he also went on a very long rant
slamming certain republicans
remember this democrats don't have
grandstanders like mitt romney little
ben sass
richard burr bill cassidy susan collins
lisa murkowski pat toomey
[Applause]
and in the house tom rice
south carolina adam kinzinger
dan newhouse anthony gonzalez that's
another beauty
fred upton jamie herrera butler
peter meyer john catko david
valadeo and of course the war monger
a person that loves seeing our troops
fighting
liz cheney how about that so what is
this
all about quite simply this is about
trump
wanting to control the republican party
and to be
king maker trump doesn't yet know
whether he will run in 2024
because it's not clear what his position
in the republican
party is going to be at that time that's
almost four years away
for now most voters in the republican
party still support donald trump
but many republican elected officials
don't and trump's best
path to 2024 is to be a king maker
successfully in 2022. in order to do
that
he needs to control the donor money of
the republican party
and this has set up a major propaganda
and legal battle between donald trump
and the republican party
which is just exploding the republican
party says
it has the right period to use trump's
name and likeness
for fundraising purposes donald trump
has sent the republican party a cease
and desist letter
saying stop using my name stop using my
likeness
to raise money for the republican party
trump wants to raise the money
himself for his pack and then decide who
to support in 2022
and which republicans to try to primary
and remove in 2022 and he doesn't want
to be competing
with his own name and image used by the
republican party
to raise money maybe as he would see it
to support the wrong republicans he
doesn't want
his name being used to raise money by
the gop to then support the re-election
of liz cheney for example or
mitt romney for example so the legal
battle is going to continue
i don't know how that will go i mean
it's a does the republican party have a
right
to monetize a former president's name
and likeness i don't know the answer to
that that's a legal question
but in the meantime donald trump has
released a wild
attack letter the likes of which we've
never seen
ever from a former president against
their own party
writing yesterday in a statement by
donald j
trump no more money for rhinos rhino
means republican
in name only they do nothing but hurt
the republican party and our great
voting base
they will never lead us to greatness
send your donation
to saveamericapac donaldjump.com
we will bring it all back stronger than
ever before
a former republican president is saying
do not
donate to my party to the republican
party donate to me
instead a former president sending a
cease and desist letter
to their own party saying don't mention
me
in trying to raise money and so this is
unprecedented of course but it's a grift
on a few different
layers first of all trump wants to
control the money
because that's trump's whole life
control the money not someone else
that that's been trump's entire career
number two
republican voters are willing to donate
some amount of money each election cycle
trump wants it to go to him rather than
to someone else
so that he can play king maker secondly
trump can't tolerate any dissent
so he has this list of enemy republicans
rhinos
who he might even try to get primary
challengers
against for 2022 and he wants to control
that that's another reason why he says
donate to him not to the republican
party
and third he wants to keep his options
open for 2024. and in order to do that
him controlling the republican party in
2022
is the natural and most obvious path now
there's maybe a fourth
which is trump maybe can use some of
this money
either towards campaign debt or keep it
if he does eventually run in 2024
instead of using it in 2022
that really depends on the specifics of
how this pack is set up i emailed a
couple of lawyers this morning
asking whether this is possibly what
trump is also doing
haven't heard back yet so we'll look
into that more but that's potentially
the fourth layer of the grift
and that's what trump did with his
fundraising i think it was 70
something million after the november
2020 election saying give me money
to try to overturn the election results
and
fund recounts in georgia and all this
stuff he kept most of the money for uh
his own campaign debt so
that's the latest with trump trump and
the republican party now
they're officially at war this is trump
declared war against
a certain slate of republicans at a cpac
speech two weeks ago
and now donald trump declaring legal war
against the republican party
sending a cease and desist letter hey
this is very interesting there's this
republican congressman dan crenshaw
from texas we've talked about him in the
past he has one of the most
gerrymandered districts i've ever seen
if you look at the shape of the district
it's like a crescent moon
uh it has no basis in uh
um it makes no sense it's really the
prototypical example of gerrymandering
and dan crenshaw is seen uh by many on
the right as sort of a different type of
republican
uh millennial and uh more
savvy when it comes to social media and
the internet and
sort of some kind of truth teller and
you know not like the old guard
republicans well the daily beast now
reports
that although congressman dan crenshaw
didn't buy or sell any stocks in his
first 13 months as a congressman in
march of 2020
when the pandemic hit he made about half
a dozen
of um the uh half a dozen
buys of stocks and he did not
disclose those right away he delayed
disclosure
chalking it up to a clerical error five
of those purchases
came between march 25 and 27 that is
exactly when the senate and house were
voting on the cares act
and trump signed it into law this was
the first coronavirus stimulus
crenshaw supported the bill didn't
disclose
his stock trades in violation of the
stock act which requires members of
congress to tell the public
when they do any securities trading
months later
he amended the records to say oh back in
march
i made these trades and when his office
was asked about it
they said these were clerical errors now
to be clear
senators kelly loffler and david perdue
were moving
millions of dollars in stock but these
trades
by dan crenshaw we're talking about six
figures they add up to no more than a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars but
remember
dan crenshaw has a lot less money than
lefleur and perdue
but the timing is very very much suspect
and it makes
us wonder why he made the purchases
and in two series of disclosures didn't
mention the purchases
later did and now says that it's merely
a clerical error and uh nothing uh
whatsoever to see here and you what's
crazy is
i have done more disclosure of my uh
pandemic related stock trades
than has dan crenshaw or then had dan
crenshaw in
april in march when i made the trades
and by the way i
i just i just have a show i've no reason
to disclose anything but i do
uh i came to you guys and i said i made
some stock trades on the basis of the
pandemic
uh live nation which does live events
crashed
i believe eventually live events will
come back so i bought live nation stock
uh i bought roku stock thinking i've
already owned netflix for years i'm not
gonna get more netflix stock but with
people at home
i think roku will do really well zoom
with so many people working from home
possibly indefinitely
my i said i bought zoom i did more
disclosure
uh than dan crenshaw did so is this
something
is it nothing the point is the guy
frames himself
as not like everybody else this is the
new breed of millennial
republican who's uh you know different
he is different in that he's not nearly
as wealthy as a lot of these other
folks who have been trading stock but he
seems to be just like everybody else and
you
if you want to know more about dan
crenshaw and his antics check out
some of my other videos including um
analyses
of an appearance he did with joe rogan
where he says some really
strange things about socialism and
healthcare um
but when i'm doing more disclosure than
elected officials
you know that something has gone very
very wrong and dan crenshaw
indistinguishable from these other
republicans
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
we got a voicemail from the eggman he
believes
that the so-called concept of freedom of
religion is bogus because it doesn't
apply to all religions equally
let's let the egg man say it himself
like only he can
hey dave and pat i think freedom of
religion is overrated
no i think freedom of religion shouldn't
be a thing anymore it's complete
[ __ ] it's totally subjective and
this ban on full face
coverings in switzerland is 100 a good
thing
sorry guys but i'm totally for it you
shouldn't be able to cover your entire
face in public
it's a safety problem in our country in
any country
yeah you can wear a mask for health
reasons of course here's the deal guys
people are using freedom of religion do
the most insane
things okay and it's not that they're
doing insane things they're refusing
other people to do and save things aka
spaghetti monster
satanism i have a religion that is not
acknowledged
by this country or by the world and i
don't get freedom of religion
i smoke marijuana for my religion it
harms no one
right illegal where i live how come some
people
can cover their entire face or do
horrible things
in the name of their religion but i
can't smoke a bowl when i come home
to bring my prayers up to god because
that's what my culture tells me
freedom of religion is freaking stupid
we have to stop it
it's going to cause tons more problems
in the future on this planet
shalom brother all right so there is the
eggman
shot out of a cannon with a principled
and defiant speech
supporting the face covering ban in
switzerland which we discussed yesterday
on the bonus show all right on today's
bonus show
we will talk about the fallout from the
harry and megan interview there's a
really interesting media story there
we will talk about the latest in the
george floyd case which is now
going to be delayed and we will talk
about a risk factor for kovid
not getting that much attention but it
correlates with
78 of those hospitalized
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get
instant access to the bonus show by
getting a membership at joinpacman.com
that's option number one
or becoming a patron at patreon.com
david pakman show that is option number
two
i will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman